it is the most significant moment in the
war since Putin invaded Ukraine in
February 2022 on June 23rd Evgeni
pragosian the leader of the Wagner
mercenary group mutinied capturing
rostov and Don a critical Russian
military logistics Hub control
I'm marching his militia towards Moscow
but just a day later it was all over
progression struck a deal with Putin
agreeing to turn back his troops what
does this sudden town of events mean for
the war in Ukraine Russia and the world
The Economist defense editor Shashank
Joshi Reveals His three key takeaways
thank you
ukrainians have sought to capitalize on
the chaos inside Russia and they have
made some gains on the ground in the
east of the country particularly around
the town of bakmud but I think the
bigger impact on this war is going to be
over the medium and longer term because
we've seen uh divisions and tensions
within Russia's military command laid
bare and if you're a Russian soldier on
the ground you will just have heard
evgeny pragosian explain why the war is
being fought for the benefit of corrupt
Elites and is unnecessary you will just
have watched Wagner mercenaries shoot
down your pilot and get away with it and
if you're a Wagner Soldier you will have
been shot at shelled bombed by Russian
soldiers alongside whom you may now have
to fight in Ukraine so you can imagine
the kind of poisonous effect that's
going to have on Battlefield Dynamics
there was an assumption that the longer
this war goes on the more that Western
democracies uh that America Europe would
struggle to keep up and keep Focus what
I think has now become clear as of June
24th is that a long campaign is also
going to exacerbate the stresses and the
strains on Putin's regime as well that a
long war is not necessarily going to
benefit Russia
the events of June 24th have left
Vladimir Putin severely weakened he has
survived he has staved off this coup
attempt he has stopped Wagner's march on
Moscow but he's also made a compromise
with a man whom he described as a
traitor and he's been forced to allow
him to escape punishment to leave for
Belarus to have his militia the Wagner
group retain its weapons and I think
what people are seeing inside Russia
Putin's Rivals are that he wasn't able
to stop this by force he wasn't able to
prevent this from happening in the first
place despite having intelligence and I
think his opponent will sniff weakness I
think this leaves the Putin regime more
brittle more fragile perhaps than ever
before
there is a recognition in Western
capitals now that they have to reckon
with a scenario that was previously seen
as more outlandish which is the fall of
the Putin regime and perhaps even chaos
turmoil Civil War inside Russia that
could mean refugees into Europe it could
mean questions around the security and
safety of Russia's nuclear Arsenal and
it could mean new Warlords like the
Chechen leader ramzan kadirov asserting
themselves in the aftermath of that kind
of turmoil
this is the first time that anybody has
seriously challenged Moscow on the
ground since Hitler in operation
Barbarossa in the early 1940s it's the
first really serious coup in Moscow
since the 1991 coup by KGB hardliners
that also failed I think when a
government has been around for 23 years
as Putin's has done it begins to look
like a permanent fixture on the world
scene but I think this is now reminding
us that big Imperial Wars in Russia have
often resulted in the chickens coming
home to roost and instability back in
the capital at home
thank you for watching and to read more
of our fantastic coverage on the war in
Ukraine please click on the link
brilliant